hello John Perry here welcome to the
first ever whatsit Wednesday here on
stated casually I know a lot of you are
probably wanting to see the next
Creation Museum video the next Ark
Encounter museum video I am working on
that don't worry it will be up shortly
but first yeah I just wanted to
kick-start this new segment on the on
that YouTube channel what's it Wednesday
can you figure out what this animal is
this is a real skull you can even see
the inner ear bones still intact inside
they're spectacular specimen
look at those teeth
yeah every week I'm gonna do a skull or
a feather you tell me what animal the
feather came from you know what species
of bird or what species of animal these
skull came from and so on and we're just
gonna keep doing that I don't know until
we all get bored of it
there's no prizes or anything but if you
get the answer right you have the joy of
being right on the internet so that's
always fun this specimen is really
fascinating look at these teeth the
teeth on this thing the back teeth act
kind of like scissors and that they put
the giant hair they sliced down like
that it's just perfect fairly large
brain case hopefully you can kind of get
an idea of the size just you know
compared to my hand
it's about size of my hand
what could this creature be is it a
chupacabra is it a vampire bat is it a
dinosaur
you
look at that beautiful bone structure
inside the nose turbinates that's what
they're called
so next week next Wednesday I will
upload the sequel to the first what's it
Wednesday it'll be the second what's it
Wednesday and I'll tell you what this is
and then I'll reveal to you a new quiz
so yeah fun little program look at that
those top teeth there's like a little
tiny tooth back there and the front here
we've got three on each side so six all
together then these big giant fangs
those are called canines
it's a beautiful skull
here we can see the sutures of the skull
goes across the top here and there's
another suture going down this way
another suture coming up this way then
we have sutures down the nose cool
good luck with guessing what this is